So today we're going to start talking
about classical utilitarianism and we're
going to use as our,
as our point of departure,
Jeremy Bentham,
uh,
who lived between 1748 and 1832 and came
up with the canonical statement of the
doctrine of utilitarianism.
It's a doc train,
which is still very much alive and kicking
and the contemporary west despite all
of its problems. And we'll have
things to say about why that is.
But I wanted to make a couple of prefatory
remarks first about Bentham himself
that there is some think is in,
in a western tradition,
I guess in any tradition who have a
particular characteristic that um,
Bentham certainly has. And I think
of the folks we're going to read,
Karl Marx had and Robert Nozick had.
And the,
the thing I'm thinking of here is they
are the kind of person who takes one idea
to the most extreme possible formulation.
They asked themselves the question,
how would the world be if this idea that
I have is that is the only important
idea?
And they take it to its logical extreme
to an excessive kind of formulation.
And they will go places with their
idea that nobody else will go.
Um, and so that makes them
a little bit crazy. Um,
you know, their motto I
call obsessive leak, uh,
consumed with their idea.
In the case of Bentham,
it's the idea of utility, which we're
going to unpack a little bit, uh,
in the moment.
Um,
but what's always interesting about
people like this is that they play out an
idea to its logical extreme and that
exhibits both its strengths and its
limitations because it's just because
they're willing to go when others will not
go think the unthinkable,
think politically very incorrect
things for their time in pursuit of,
of really pushing this idea
to the absolute health.
And so Bentham is a kind of thinker who,
um,
I suspect at the end of the day,
nobody will be fully convinced by,
but he's very useful.
He's a very useful, um,
diagnostician of what,
what it is about utilitarianism that's
going to be appealing to you and where
eventually you're going to want to put
some limits on it just because he goes
beyond the limits. And so
you can see what happens. Um,
if you push it all the way to the hilt.
Secondly,
I wanted to just say that
Bentham is important, um, as a,
as a fountain of more than Utilitarian
Nissam but also of modern conceptions of
value more generally considered.
Um,
you'll see that he is one of the,
there were the,
there were rumblings of the kinds of
things he had to say about value in the
17th century.
Hobbes for example,
who I mentioned last time criticized
Aristotle for not seeing that what is good
for some people may not be
good for other people. Um,
and Bentham builds on that idea.
Uh,
you'll see Bentham,
we'll start to link the good to
what it is that people desire.
Um, it, there were also rumblings
of Bentham's methods in,
in particularly his aspirations to found
politics on scientific principles in
the 17th century.
We already saw last time the hubs,
Yana and Lockian creationist
theories of science,
but they were really transitional figures.
They also gave a theological
justifications for their arguments.
As I explained at some length in
lock, uh, in the context of lock.
I didn't have time to do it with Hobbs,
but many of you will know that if you
read the the second two thirds of Hobbs'
Leviathan,
it's almost all about interpretation
of the scriptures showing that uh,
his scientifically derived principles
are also consistent with the Bible.
Bentham sheds all of this for Bentham.
Um,
he's not interested in
appeals to tradition.
He's not interested in
appeals to religion.
appeals to natural law.
He dismisses the natural law tradition
as dangerous nonsense nonsense on stilts.
He's only interested in a scientific set
of principles for organizing politics.
And one of the nice things about Bentham,
at least from your point of view is um,
and we'll see that utilitarianism
values efficiency in in many ways.
But one of the interesting things or
the helpful things about Bell Bentham is
that he reduces his whole doctrine to
a single paragraph and he puts that
paragraph right at the front
of his introduction to the
principles of morals and
legislation.
So yeah,
you have the kind of cliff notes
formulation of Bentham's argument.
He says that nature has placed mankind
under the governance of two
sovereign masters pain and pleasure.
It is for them alone to point out what
we ought to do as well as to determine
what we shall do.
So this is going to be about describing
human behavior and about what ought to
be the case,
right?
What we shall do to determine what we
ought to do is to point out why we ought
to do as well as to determine
what we shall do. On the one hand,
the standard of right
and wrong on the other,
that chain of causes and effects
are fastened to their throne.
That's the throne of pain and pleasure.
They govern us in all
we do and all we say,
and in all we think every effort we
can make to throw off our subjection.
That's how subjection to pleasure
seeking and pain avoiding will serve,
but to demonstrate and confirm it,
to confirm that objection in words,
a man may pretend to
have juror their empire.
That's the empire of pain and pleasure,
but in reality,
he will remain subject to it.
All the while.
The principle of utility recognizes
this subjection and assumes it for the
foundation of that system,
the object of which is to repair the
fabric of Felicity by the hands of reason
and law system,
which it systems which attempt to question
it deal in sounds instead of senses
in caprice instead of reason and
in darkness instead of light.
That is in a Nacelle Bentham's theory.
Okay,
very bold,
unequivocal statement.
He's saying if you want to understand
human beings in a causal explanatory
sense,
all you have to know about them is that
they're going to seek pleasure and avoid
pain.
And if you want to think about what
ought to happen in the design of
institutions they need,
they should be designed around
that fact to accommodate that fact.
And he is going to develop a system
of laws, a system of government,
uh,
that that takes into account in his belt
upon this assumption about human nature
as he would have called it human
psychology, as we would call it today.
Now I'm going to make five points about
Bentham system to give you some sense of
the full dimensions of it.
Before we start this disecting it and
subjecting it to critical scrutiny.
Want to make sure that we understand
exactly what his system is.
I want to first of all notice that it is
what I'm going to call a comprehensive
and account.
I call it a comprehensive
and deterministic account
in that it's an account of
all human behavior.
He wants to say everything you do is
ultimately determined by pleasure seeking
and pain,
avoiding
how plausible.
Who thinks that's plausible?
Hands up plausible
implausible.
Okay.
Give us an example.
Somebody of something that is
not pleasure seeking or pain,
avoiding anybody.
Something that is not the result
of pleasure seeking pain. Avoiding
while you put your hands up, you must've
had some thoughts. Yeah. Oh, okay. Yeah.
You, yeah. You take the
fire to rescue people.
Pardon?
Running into a fire to rescue people
running into a fire to rescue people.
Okay.
You run into a fire to rescue people.
What do you think Bentham would say
about that example? Yeah. Over here, sir,
the pleasure is actually
saving the people,
so there is like this
benefit that you get from it.
Pleasure you get from having saved,
the people must outweigh the pain
of the file or you wouldn't do it.
Any other example?
Nobody's got an exam son. Nobody
can think of an example. No.
Yes,
yes sir.
Um, will there may be some, for
example, saving one's child,
maybe purely instinctual
rather than driven by pain
or say sacrificing your
life to save your child.
Let's say they put in an extreme case. Why
would rent them say about that? I mean,
this seems like a genuinely altruistic,
um,
action. Somebody lays down
their life for their own child.
How can that be pleasure seeking and pain
avoiding? What would Bentham say? Yeah,
that way we need to,
could relieve the pain of having lost a
child like outweighs whatever pleasures.
Yeah, I think that is what he would
say. Think of the counterfactual.
How could I live with myself for the
rest of my life? If I didn't do it?
The pain would be too great.
And Bentham considers cases like that.
There's this sort of thing.
Apparently altruistic acts,
same ultimately always reduceable to
the pleasure cane calculus one example.
He considers his people acting from
religious motivations. And he says,
Ha, just read the Bible. You know,
look at the descriptions
of Heaven and hell.
Isn't that a made to order?
Pleasure seeking and pain avoidance.
Hell is described as, you know,
the fires of Hell,
perpetual pain.
So the people who constructed religious
doctrines clearly had an understanding
of human nature or they wouldn't have
described hell in a way that they
described it and heaven in
the way that they describe it.
So the f,
the first thing he wants to say is
that this is a completely comprehensive
explanation of human behavior.
Okay.
Can,
can anybody think of any example that
couldn't be read described as fitting this
pleasure? Pain Calculus. Yeah.
Thinks that if life is all about pain
and pleasure and we will be willing to
replace our load with one with own,
I'm in one only with pleasure, right?
But we wouldn't,
we've all your life by yourself,
there's something indescribable
quality to it. I mean,
love Pfister some of old
experiences rather than just
playing pain and pleasure,
sir.
So you think that there is more
complexity to human motivation?
Um,
that's just not expressible as a
reduceable to pain and pleasure.
I think, you know, that was a,
that's a very sophisticated and common
critique that's been made of Bentham.
If you go and read and indeed if you read
the obituary of him that was written,
um,
okay.
By Coleridge,
I think it was,
it makes exactly this point that
there was this sophistication to human
motivation that isn't captured in
this idea. I think that the truth has,
Bentham would have acknowledged some of
that, but he would have said, you know,
at the end of the day it's
unimportant because the pleasure,
pain calculus overrides
when the chips are down.
If we're going to think about what it is
that's going to motivate people, it's,
it's, um, pleasure seeking
and pain avoidance.
Okay.
A second thing that you should
notice about this doctrine is that,
I'm going to call it a
naturalistic doctrine in some ways.
It's astounding that writing almost
half a century before Darwin,
Darwin was born in 1809
and lift till 1882,
so writing almost half a
century before Darwin. Um,
Bentham grounds his
principle in the apparent,
in the imperatives for human survival.
Okay.
He thinks that the pleasure pain
principle has a natural biological basis,
although there are religious,
moral and political sources and
sanctions of pain and pleasure.
These are all secondary to the
physical sources for Bentham.
The physical, he refers at one point
as the groundwork of the political,
moral and religious.
It is included in each of them.
At another point he says, we are bound
by the principle of utility as, uh,
the natural constitution
of the human frame. Often,
unconsciously and office
when often went out,
conscious explanations for our actions
are inconsistent with the principle of
utility.
I'll come back to that point.
If we didn't abide by
the principle of utility,
he says in his little essay on the
economic psychology of man, he says,
quote,
the human species could not continue
in existence and that in a few months,
not to say week,
so days we would would be all that
would be needed for its annihilation.
In other words,
the principle of utility expresses our
objective interests as living creatures.
Okay.
A third point that I'm going to make
about Bentham's doctrine is that it's what
I will call egoistic,
but not subjectivist.
Now that's a lot of babble terminology
and let me explain what it means.
The reason I'm using those two words
together is that they don't normally go
together.
That is to say egoistic views
are usually subjectivists.
So I'm, I'm pointing out that
they're not. And by Egoistic,
I mean it is,
uh,
just like in wall economics assumptions,
assumption of self interest,
people are self interested,
seek as off to pleasure
and self interested.
Avoid is a pain in exactly the way you
learn about them in an economics 101 a
textbook. Um, and we'll,
we'll have occasion to examine
that self interested premise,
uh,
in some depth later,
but it's not a subjectivist doctrine in
that Bentham wants to say this is true.
Regardless of what we ourselves
say about our preferences,
it's not dependent upon a,
your acknowledging it's
truth for it's being true.
Okay.
So you might think you're motivated by
altruism or love of your child or your
religious faith. Bentham says
you're just muddled and diluted.
You don't understand,
uh,
your subjective understanding is not in
accord with the science of the matter.
Um,
at one of,
at one point he says it
is with the anatomy of the
human mind as it is with the
anatomy and physiology of the human body.
The rare case is not of a man's being
unconverted hunt but of his being
conversant with it.
So just as you know,
if you have a pain in your side and you
don't know if it's your liver or your
spleen or your long, uh, you know,
the rare case as you get it right,
um,
he wants to do is exactly the
same with your motivation.
The fact that you don't understand or
wouldn't agree with or don't acknowledge
what's motivating you so
much the worst for you.
You just have an inaccurate or incomplete
understanding of your motivation.
You just wrong. Okay. So it's in
that sense picks up on the idea.
This is an objectivist account. People
are, it's, it is objectively the case.
Whatever people think about it,
whatever people say about it,
it is objective may be the case
that they behave self interest.
The Lea and the pursuit of
pleasure and the avoidance of pain.
Fourth Bentham's is a radically
consequentialist doctrine.
Anyone know what that might mean?
Anyone want to tell us what is our,
what do you think I might mean by
calling it a consequentialist doctrine?
Yeah.
Yes ma'am.
Um,
that in being motivated by pleasure
and pain were concerned with the
consequences of our actions. If we
know something's going to be painful,
we'll avoid it. And if it's going to
be pleasurable, will move towards it.
Yeah. But as I said at the
beginning of the electric,
Bentham takes everything to the extreme.
So if we are concerned with
the consequences of our,
of the action and nothing else,
it's an extreme
consequentialist doctorate.
He's not interested in our intentions,
right?
The road to hell is paved with
good intentions for Bentham. No,
doesn't matter what people intend.
It matters what happens, right?
It's a radically
consequentialist doctrine.
We will see that there's an alternative
tradition of thinking about ethics and
politics that is deeply
rooted in human intentions.
When we come to,
um,
to read Robert Nozick and John
Rawls and people who draw on cons.
Emmanuel [inaudible] ethics.
But,
and that's what gets to
you to give you all of the,
the jargon a upfront that is what
will be called de ontological.
Um,
sometimes contrast that with teleological
consequentialist is a kind of
teleological doctrine.
What is teleological main?
Anybody?
Yeah,
at the back
teleological system.
Well,
given that a telos in Greek is the end,
the end,
that's purpose. The
consequence. Exactly right.
So consequential as doctrines I
like are teleological doctrines.
They're all about the consequences, the
purpose, the end, the goals, the results.
Whereas what we will talk about later
when we get to day ontological systems are
the antithesis of that.
They are focus on intentions,
on processes, on procedures,
on high, on how you do things,
not on where you get to.
Okay.
So Bentham is a radical
consequentialist and
you judge a doctrine simply
by looking you judge a,
a possible policy and action.
Anything you thinking of doing or not
doing simply by virtue of what effect that
is likely to have and nothing else,
nothing else matters.
Finally,
Bentham. Thanks everything
he's doing this quantifiable.
Yeah,
no,
I gave you just a sliver to read from
his introduction to the principles of
morals and legislation,
just so that you could get a sense
of how this guy's mind actually work.
He really thought it was the case that
he could develop a kind of science of
utilitarianism where he would figure
out exactly how many you tells you.
We might call them, we might call
them standard international utiles.
The Siu would attached
to a of pleasure or pain,
any policy or action,
and that eventually you could figure
out exactly what all of the optimal
policies were for the
Organization of society.
He thought about utility.
He thought it had really four dimensions.
How intense is it? Duration,
how long does it last?
It's certainty or uncertainty.
That is probability that
the result will occur.
And it's what we, what he called
propinquity or remoteness, which we would,
modern economist would say, we discount
pleasure into their future. Um,
so our dollar is more that if you'll say,
I'll give you a dollar today or
I'll give you a dollar tomorrow,
you'll get more utility from the
dollar that you get today. Okay.
So he, he thought that these were all
quantifiable dimensions of utilities,
a little unsure about the intensity,
um,
but he's sure that everything
else can be quantified.
And he sat about quantifying,
uh,
he set about trying to figure
out a system of legislation,
not only for his society,
by the way,
he started writing constitutions for
other countries and when he ran off to
Poland and various places and,
and said, hey, look, here's my,
my utilitarian constitution
for your country.
And he was very disappointed when people
didn't rush off and implemented a right
away. So, you know, he,
he truly believed that you
could come up with a, uh,
scientifically demonstrably demonstrable
system of organizing society based on
the quantify tie ball
character of utilitarianism.
So one further feature of
this quantifiable character
of utilitarianism is that
he thought we could make
comparisons across people.
We could do the math across people.
We could add up
how much utility one person gets from a
possible action and how much you tell or
the or this utility another person gets
and redistribute in order to do what he
thought we should do,
which was to maximize the greatest
happiness of the greatest number.
He's a complete consequentialist.
So we would do whatever we have to do to
maximize the greatest happiness of the
greatest number.
So for example,
I happen to know that Denise,
who's sitting over there is it has
got a great capacity for utility.
She's easily pleased. She,
uh, you know, if you give her,
if you give her a book, she'll be just
the lighting. But Antonio over the eyes,
kind of grumpy guy, you know, if
you give him a book is say, well,
why didn't you give me two bucks?
You know, one measly buck. You know,
so if I have a choice between giving
this book to Denise or giving the book to
Antony,
I'm going to give the book to Denise
because she's going to get more utility
than Anthony's going to get a,
from having this buck.
And we don't really care who has the
utility from a social perspective,
we want a great,
maximize the greatest happiness
of the greatest number.
Okay.
But then what we might discover is
that layer Neda over there has an even
greater capacity for utility.
He is just a utility monster.
Um,
he's got such a capacity for happiness
that any little thing that most of us
would think, it's neither here nor there.
I was really going to make him happy.
Well then we should give everything
to him, right? So it's, it's,
it's a doctrine that's completely
uninterested in the distributor side of
utilitarianism except
in an instrumental way.
We'll come back to that on a next Monday,
uh,
or you want to do is maximize the greatest
happiness of the greatest number in
society,
the total amount of happiness.
Okay.
Now here's a further feature of Bentham's
doctrine and I think it follows from
the consequentialism that
you should at least notice,
cause I think it will bears
on our thinking about,
for instance, the
Eichmann problem. Um, and
this, this is actually taken
from Robert Nozick book,
who you're going to read later in
the semester in his critique of
utilitarianism.
He says,
let's consider the following
thought experiment. Suppose,
um,
you were cut,
your brain was connected to electrodes
to buy electrodes to a computer and the
computer was programmed to make
you have whatever experiences,
give you pleasure and not to have
any experiences that give you pain.
And you were to him. So you would,
you would in fact be unconscious.
I think actually in nozicks example,
floating in a Vat,
I'm conscious,
but you would believe you were doing
whatever it is that gives you the greatest
pleasure.
And the question now is a cas is,
would you want to be
connected to the machine?
Who would want to be connected
to the machine? Okay.
We only have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
15.
I see about 15 candidates for Nozick
splasher machine who would not want to be
connected to this machine.
Okay.
We Ha we have a probably two
thirds of it of you who's not sure.
Okay. Some are not sure who, those
who wouldn't want to be connected.
Why not? I mean, this is great,
isn't it? You have to work anymore.
You don't have to do assignments. You
don't have to show up to class. You just,
you know, for the rest of your
life. Maybe your program too,
to have the experiences that give
you the most pleasure in life.
What could be better than that? Why
don't you want to do it? Yeah. Over here.
Yeah.
I think the point of life is to have
like a complexity of experiences and
without experiencing pain at some point,
pleasure wouldn't be a sweet.
Okay.
The point of life is to hold onto the mic.
I just want to put the follow this alone,
the, the point of life is to have some,
some contrast effects. You
know, Richard Nixon said,
only if you've been in the deepest value,
can you appreciate the joy of being on
the highest mountain as he was being run
out of the White House in 1974.
Uh,
well you could say,
okay,
well in that case we'll
program the machine accordingly
so you'll have, you know,
you'll have certain painful experiences
in order to maximize the neck of
pleasure and pain. So we, you know,
uh, you know, every, I don't know,
you know,
every fifth minute you'll have
some unpleasant experience
just so that you don't
forget how pleasant the
pleasant experiences, you
know, we can, we can do that.
All right,
well then you wouldn't be like having
freewill and experiencing the various,
okay, so that's different, right?
It's not the contrast. It's,
it's not the banality of
pleasure. A, if you like, it's,
it's that the lack of freewill
or autonomy, but coding,
we program it to make you thank, you were
acting freely even though you weren't,
I think. Um, what about
that you think, you know,
maybe some people say that's
true of us all, you know,
the parent is this idea we have free,
well,
it's a lot of bunk were all really
basically just acting out certain impulses
and instincts. But we
believe we have free. Well,
so you could be made to believe that
you're making choices even if in fact you
aren't,
well wouldn't the like free will be as
much a component of like the natural
physical nature of man? Well
now you will his plan. Okay,
I'm adding more to,
okay, so that would be a different
theory then Bentham's theory,
but you can see where you can
see where this is going. Right.
That I think there were some
people in the room, if we,
if we had time to pursue
this conversation,
there are some people in the room who no
matter what you did to the programming
and the experience machine,
they wouldn't like it and they wouldn't
like it for two principle reasons.
I think one has just been articulated,
which is that somehow this seems like
an abdication of your own autonomy.
Um,
and you know,
as when you think back
to the Eifman problem,
one of the things that troubled people
was his abdication of his autonomy is
given his giving up.
If he's free well to say yes or no,
I think this is right or wrong.
I'm going to do it on the basis
of my own autonomous judgment.
The second thing I think that people
would worry about is who's operating the
machine,
who's operating a machine is a kind of uh,
how do you know that once they've
got you floating in that Vat,
what you wanted to have
done well in fact happen.
And so there's a basic problem of um,
agency and accountability
that makes people nervous.
But let's just put those things
to one side for the moment and
okay,
focus on the rest of the
exposition of Bentham's doctrine.
We're going to come back to all
of these issues. I promise you,
I just want to get them
everything out on the table.
What he says is that the
role of government is
a measure of government.
It's a kind of,
which is about a particular kind of
action performed by a particular person or
persons may be said to be comfortable
too or dictated by the principle of
utility in like Ma when in life man.
And the tendency,
which it has to augment the happiness of
the community is greater than any which
it has to diminish it.
So again,
the bumper sticker version of that
for Bentham is maximize the greatest
happiness of the greatest number.
And for those of you who like thinking
diagrammatically and as I noted at the,
in my opening lecture,
not everybody does,
but if we imagine a two person society,
so Aa has this much utility,
that's the status quo, right? Hey,
has this much utility B has that much
utility and let's say there's some outer
limit of possible utility,
which,
which we will call the possibility
frontier. Bentham would say any,
if you draw that line there,
anything that puts us in this Sha,
whatever it is, cloudy zone, yeah.
Would be a net increase in the total
amount of utility in the society.
Pretty straight forward plan.
Right?
So we went from there to that
both would have more utility,
but if we went from there,
say to that,
as utility would have gone up and bees
would have gone down, but we don't care.
Right? Because, um,
the total amount of utility
in this society has gone up.
What we wouldn't want to do is come
anywhere into this area because then
utility,
the total amount of utility in
the society would have decreased.
Okay?
So that's basically the story.
Now you might say,
well,
why do you need government at all?
Okay,
if this is the story,
everybody is whatever they think,
whatever they say,
whatever they understand,
everybody is a mindless pleasure seeker
and pain avoider or perhaps mindful
pleasure, secret pain and avoid it,
but they have no control over that.
They're going to just do
what they have to do. Um,
why create a government with the principle
that it should maximize utility in
the society? It seems like an odd
thing to do. Why would you do that?
Anyone?
Yeah,
so just looking at that last graph,
right?
If each person tried to
maximize their utility,
then deed both want to be on the
opposite, you know, corners of each other.
So then you would get chaos. When you
extrapolate that to a larger group,
you need something to kind of
manage everybody's pleasure.
So people won't voluntarily do
things that maximize one another's,
maximize the total social utility,
right?
If taking something from a and giving
it to be would increase speeds utility
more than it would diminish A's utility,
why is not going to go
for that voluntarily be,
might go and take it. Um, but he may
or may not be strong enough to take it.
We don't know.
So that's a very shrewd observation
in response to that diagram.
And it's actually gets to
more sophisticated questions
about redistribution and
utilitarianism that I'm going to
take up on Monday. But there's,
I think before we get to those questions,
there's a more fundamental level at which
Bentham,
thanks.
Utilitarianism creates the need for
government and that is that there's a
disconnect between what's individually
optimal and what's socially optimal.
Even before we get to the
redistributive questions,
we might call it the market
failure theory of government where,
okay,
other 18th century thinkers had taken
the view that when you know Adam Smith's
famous invisible hand,
everybody acting selfishly leads
to a collectively optimal results.
Bentham, we'll see. Thanks. That's
true a lot of the time, but not always.
There are certain circumstances in which,
okay,
people are likely not to act in a
way that produces a common result.
The great,
the great enemy enemies of public piece
or the selfish and this social passions
necessary as they are.
Society has held together only by the
sacrifices that men can be induced to May
of the gratifications.
They demand to obtain these
sacrifices is the great difficulty,
the great task of government
and he's thinking really I've,
and it's maybe the first
formulation of it that we find
what we today call free writing.
Free loading.
Okay.
He thinks about the provision of
something like national defense,
what we call economists
call a public good. You,
you can't be excluded from the
benefits of it, right? But,
and it must be jointly supplied.
So it says if for example,
the commencement or continuing of a
war being the question upon the carpet,
if upon his calculation a hundred a year
during the continuance of the war or
forever will be the amount
of the contribution,
which according to kiss calculation,
he will have to pay.
You have to pay $100 a year
in taxes to finance this war.
If his expected profit by the war
will be zero and no particular Gusta
passionate into beam to drive him from
the pursuit of what appears to be his
lasting interest upon the whole,
he will be against the war.
And what influence it may happen to him
to possess will be exerted on the other
side.
Now why would his benefit be zero?
Okay.
What's,
I mean this is rather convoluted prose,
but what Bentham saying is if the
war's going to be four to anyway,
I get no marginal benefit
from supporting it,
I might as well oppose it.
Well I might as well refuse to pay
taxes in supportive. Right, right.
And that is the nature of public goods
that people can free ride on that
provision because an economist says the
two features of a public good or they
must be jointly surprised.
Everybody has to contribute to them.
And you can't exclude anybody from
the benefits of them like clean areas.
We keep clean air for some people,
we're going to create clean
air for all people. Okay.
So people are going to have to be
coerced in the provision of public goods.
People are going to have to be
cohort coerced to pay for the war.
So that's one example.
Another one that comes up is the so
called tragedy of the Commons problem.
Suppose you have some common land,
and we'll come back to talking about
this in connection with walk a social
contract theory.
You know,
God gave the world to mankind in
common on lock story, so long as,
as much in as good as available
to have this in common. So if,
if you have common land,
he has the problem.
You thinking about
grazing with sheep on the,
if I put my sheep onto that common land,
it doesn't do any lasting damage.
But if everybody grazers,
they're sheep on the land and and
none of it's allowed to lie fallow,
then it destroys the common.
Okay,
so there are too many sheep for
everybody to graze the sheep on the land,
but any individual person doesn't
have a reason not to graze his sheep.
This was finally formulated in a rigorous
way by a man called Garrett Hardin.
The tragedy of the Commons,
that if you have Commons,
there'll be destroyed because each
person will do something that makes
individual rational sense but
not collective rational sense.
So this is, again, it's not the exactly
the same as the free riding problem,
but it's related to the
free riding problem.
I won't see any reason in the world why,
um,
I shouldn't grace my cow,
my sheep on the common.
But when everybody does that, we
destroy the common, it's a bit like,
you know, walking down the street
with a soda can and you think,
should I take the trouble to cross the
street to put it in a recycling bin?
Or just throw it in the trash,
one coke bottle, you know?
I mean, what difference one
coke was not going to make it,
but if everybody doesn't cross the
street, the same problem. Okay.
So these are the areas
where there's a disconnect.
There's a disconnect between
individual utility and social utility.
And that is what creates
the need for government.
We will pursue these questions,
uh,
and my child's about classical
utilitarianism next Monday.